Charlotte wanted to start by asking you
uh for those out there that don't know
how personal is this film in terms of
you know the basics of the elements that
you took from your life to bring to the
screen
um very personal I mean I I still assert
that it is a piece of fiction
but it's true that my own memories and
experiences
formed the basis of the script formed
the first skeleton outline that I worked
from when I wrote the first draft
and I think more than anything the
emotion expressed in the film is is mine
and that's to me what makes it the most
personal like I wasn't on this holiday
these these days did not play out as
they do in the film but I think that my
relationship with my dad was the was the
foundation of these characters and so
there is much of of me me in this
um and I understand that this took a
long time uh for you to write can you
tell us a little bit about sort of that
process of you know dig into memory and
put it on the page
yeah I think it was about like a seven
year seven and a half by this point year
process
and many of those years were rising and
trying to figure out what I wanted this
to be and in those early days it was
something a bit more conventionally
structured more driven by a plot I would
say
and I think it was always heading in
this direction it's just that that's
where I needed to begin
to get a handle on what it was and then
using my own experiences and allowing
myself to be inspired by photographs by
by my own relationships
um
what was kind of its own process
reflecting and remembering and
eventually that process became
impossible to
remove from the script it kind of found
its way in when I finally wrote and was
so
inextricably woven by that point that
even when I considered whether
the the framing device of the Rave the
the elements of memory were strictly
necessary to it it became clear that
they were because without them there
there was no film I had no idea what it
was
um but but it was a long process and
even from the point of writing the first
draft which I did I think in the
beginning of 2019 and and shared it with
Adela and pastel
it still we developed it quite
considerably from that point and over
the course of working on it and
collaborating with people even with my
cinematographer I gradually myself
understood what it was what the
different perspectives in the film were
how complicated they were and eventually
how to articulate them
um I recently read that this was a
little nerve-wracking for the two of us
producers so the waiting game and
keeping that fake and you talk about
sort of what made you believe that there
was something well you know worth
waiting for
it was an idea that
um Charlie first shared with me
over a coffee in 2019 and I've heard you
talk about this this sort of photograph
of your father that you that you looked
at or sorry photograph of you that your
father took and like how that might
expand into
what you were thinking at the time the
film would be and then this of course
being the film that you actually ended
up making and I I couldn't
stop thinking about it so even though
you know months went by and then years
went by before there was a script to to
share and talk about like I kept coming
back to that idea of the summer holiday
the way that uh Charlie had you know
described it to me and it
was just like a little nagging itch that
I had to keep scratching at so
cosine
yeah it's uh it's a it's such a delicate
beautiful piece
um you know uh Lulu's planting all these
seeds around our house you know some of
them grow very fast and some of them
grow at their own pace and I think this
one because no one else can make this
film it had to grow at its own pace and
once when Charlotte was was ready or
felt like it had shaped itself into the
thing that she wanted to go to Turkey
and create that was when
um the the it wasn't a weight
necessarily that's when the gestation
process was completed tell me about
casting about Paul and and Frankie and
you know we're talking I kind of know
that you mentioned that it's not
you before you sort of try to get away
from you know the resemble and the image
of the people that are inspired of but
here was kind of impossible succeed
um
yeah it was a process especially for
Frankie she was a discovery and we
always knew she would be we worked with
this fantastic casting director of the
sea party whose real talent of many but
is especially
um known for finding young people who
have never performed before and we had
submissions from around 800 kids it was
the height of the pandemic so much of it
was done remotely but we gave them the
opportunity to submit various videos and
eventually led to zoom calls in which we
could learn a little bit more about them
each time and they could hopefully
ideally grow with the process and be
able to show us a little bit more of
themselves each time
and that culminated in a two-day casting
session we met 16 kids in Glasgow in
February of last year in Scotland
and Frankie was the biggest surprise I
think of those kids she just came in and
showed an ability to move between
emotional states take Direction
um and kind of shake it off once the the
exercise was over in a way that really
suggested a innate an extraordinary
ability to act
and once we got to the end of that
process
she's also a lot of fun to be around
which was uh you know a joy and made the
process a lot easier and once we got
toward the end of that
we started to consider more seriously
who Callum was
um and Paul's name came up quite early
in that process but he was unavailable
and I remember getting quite excited
about the idea of him and and how to set
aside
but production dates moved as production
days too and and it opened up this
opportunity to share the script and we
just had this conversation that was so
thoughtful and I really felt like
we hadn't shared the script widely but
he just understood it so
clearly and intimately and had a lot of
empathy for the character and was asking
very interesting questions and we just
connected
and he made a very clear how hard he was
willing to work and how he wanted to
partner and collaborate and the time
that he put in building that
relationship with Frankie was just
phenomenal I can't imagine anybody else
have
having built the relationship the way
that he did
anything you guys want to add on this
lovely casting pair that you guys that
Charlie achieve no I think they're both
awesome I'm shocked at how much they
look like a young Charlotte and her dad
I hadn't seen those photos until 8 24
tweeted them yesterday there were photos
on the internet of Charlotte's actual uh
father and uh and her as a young child
on vacation on holiday and I was like
whoa but it's totally fictitious
with like three people who read that
newsletter
instead I've shared them with the world
yeah it's always my intention in casting
if you're casting someone who is in a
cipher to some degree of you to Cast
Away
as far as possible
and that had been my intention and
clearly it is something I failed at
doing and that probably is because the
film was so personal I think I tried
more with Sophie than I did with Callum
it was harder to do that with Callum
even conceptually was to Cast Away I
always drifted back
so I think that is less surprising than
than Frankie and to be fair Frankie
after production took a picture of me
into the hairdresser
and I copied my haircut at the time so
there was a period we were very much
doppelgangers and after the premiere
which my mom attended
she she saw Frankie for a moment of
thought it was me
forget the fact this is a 12 year old
which is troubling on many levels but um
yeah there's definitely resemblance
there and I think that speaks to how
hard it ultimately was to
to separate myself from the process of
making this you know now that the
families are in the war and into the
process did it sort of make you did you
discover something new about those
memories did you see them in a in a
different light it was a sort of
revelatory uh in a way that maybe
couldn't have happened without you
making the film
um and I wonder you guys could comment
about you know your own relationship to
the film and memory
I don't know that it's reframed memories
that I had so much as I think
I made this only because I had to make
this film it's one of
it's the only thing I've made where I
can't point to a really clear
starting point which is often an image
you know it was it was a film that just
came to be that I had to make and I had
no choice to make and I think
it's
been valuable to me to to make it and go
through that process and
explore what I I think I needed to
explore and remember what I needed to
remember and it's been very gratifying
to watch other people connect with the
film and take the space that's there and
fill it with their own experiences and
ultimately connect to the emotion that
is expressing at the end
okay
um I would say now that people are are
experiencing the film I've really
enjoyed
how often people come back to me and
they they want confirmation that their
interpretation of the film is the
correct interpretation and it goes it's
a whole spectrum of what people are
coming back and saying tell me this is
what happened or tell me that he did
this or you know and
and I just think that's really beautiful
and speaks to the fact that people are
connecting and that they're just so
passionate about the experience that
they're having
um the sort of full emotional cathartic
experience of the film for them and how
they can find themselves in it or find
their family in it um it's been that's
been really special
uh I'll go more macro just uh you know I
was saying to to Charlie last night you
know uh Friday October 21st and that
only happens every six years and so six
years ago on this Friday October 21st
Moonlight came out in theaters and so
six years ago to the day we were sitting
on a stage doing the same thing uh for a
different film and the 20 of you here
notwithstanding uh last night we were at
uh the AMC for like the public q a and
it was a sold out theater
um and we'll be again tonight and the
same thing at the Angelica in New York
and it's kind of cool to see that this
film moves at a very different Rhythm uh
than the films that are typically
filling the other 14 screens at a 16
screen Multiplex
um and yet there's an audience for this
Rhythm and I think just sitting at the
front of the stage and doing the Q a
with the Charlotte last night and
listening to seeing so many young people
bro I've seen so many young people
um sitting in the first few rows and
hopefully drinking in these images same
way they drink in the Avengers and
Ant-Man and all that stuff I think
there's something really wonderful about
that I think it just shows that you know
all the photos on the wall out there you
know of all those really amazing
filmmakers you know those same photos
apply to someone like Charlotte and a
story like this so yeah that's kind of
what I get out of it
thank you so much for being here the
three of you thank everyone for joining
us thank you thank you guys hey and if
you dug this fill let the 20 become the
40 become the 60 become the 120 tell a
friend tell a friend tell a friend
please thank you